on on ne peut pas avoir sous une forme
ou sous une autre donner une forme de
justification aux attaques du Hamas en
ne dénonçant pas à ce jour encore 4 mois
après cela comme un mouvement terroriste
en ayant même dit que ce n'est pas des
juifs qui ont été assassinés mais des
Israéliens faisant la différence entre
des Israéliens des Juifs alors que la
charte du Hamas elle parle de Yahou
yahoud ça veut dire des Juifs elle ne
parle pas d'Israélien le Hamas veut
s'attaquer au juifs il veut s'attaquer
aux infidèles il veut s'attaquer au
monde libre donc quand quand on quand on
a
l'indessence de quelque part laisser
penser que c'est de la résistance ce
qu'a fait le Hamas on ne pourrait avoir
la dessence de ne pas être présent dans
de face à aux familles des victimes qui
ont souffert de ces déclarations qui ont
souffert de ce manque de reconnaissance
qui souffre aujourd'hui qui viennent à
laquelle la France veut rendre
hommage je crois que c'est une une
volonté é encore une fois d'apparaître à
un moment où il vaut mieux disparaître
même si eux disent qu'ils ont toujours
condamné ces attaques pour vous vous
l'entendez pas ça non non je je
n'entends pas condamner on condamne
toujours quel quel est le citoyen du
monde qui ne va pas condamner des
assassinats mais on a pu laisser penser
que tu es mes cousins en Israël que tu
es des enfants assassiné des enfants
décapité violé des femmes une femme a
été violée par 27 personnes différentes
éventrer des femmes enceintes brûler des
corps c'est de la résistance on a pu
laisser penser ça dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons et ces personnesl
veulent être face aux personnes qui ont
perdu dans ces conditions leurs êtres
les plus
chers c'est une insulte c'est une
insulte aux Juifs c'est une insulte à
Israël c'est une insulte à la résistance
la résistance ce n'est pas prendre un
bébé et le le faire le faire otage c'est
une insulte au à la majorité du monde
musulman qui peut pas se reconnaître
dans ce massacre terroriste du Hamas
c'est fondamental que toutes les forces
de notre société cette société que
j'aime dans laquelle je vis cette France
dans laquelle je vis c'est fondamental
qu'il n'y ait plus une personne qui
considère que ça peut être de la
résistance et que ça peut être autre
chose que du que du terrorisme c'est du
terrorisme c'est une volonté d'aniler un
peuple c'est une volonté 80 ans après la
choix de dé
le peuple juif l'État juif c'est il faut
le dire clairement pour pouvoir bien
combattre ce
mal